a good friend Geraldo Rivera he was at
the White House today with Ivanka Trump
and Jared Kushner see that that's a
selfie by the way a safe selfie he's
gonna tell us all about it in a minute
all right but first we're learning more
damning information about the illegal
immigrants that the mayor of Oakland
California is trying to protect from
following the law and federal
immigration authorities according to the
LA Times citing ice of the 232 people
that were arrested in the latest illegal
immigration crackdown in California a
hundred and eighty were either convicted
criminals had been issued a final order
of removal or who had previously been
removed from the United States and quote
115 had prior felony convictions for
serious offenses like child sex crimes
weapons charges assault or had past
convictions for significant or multiple
misdemeanors here now with more national
security strategist dr. Sebastian Gorka
Fox News correspondent at larger Alda
Rivera you know if you're gonna the law
of the land is the law of the land you
want to change the law change the law
but when you are aiding and abetting
especially the people we're looking for
criminal aliens that have committed
crimes in this country you're putting
ice members at work Border Patrol
people's lives in jeopardy and the lives
of people in the communities in which
they live in jeopardy because most of
them are known criminals there's no
excuse for what this woman this Oakland
mayor is doing by putting people's lives
in jeopardy you know I know that I've
been out of sync with the majority of
our viewers for the 17 years I've been
here and I apologize ahead of time being
yourself don't ever apologize for being
but I as a student of history recall
learning about the compromise of 1850
where they had something called the
Fugitive Slave Act we are people in the
free states officials in the free states
were required by law to help in the
recapture of escaped slaves to return
them to their slave owners in the south
the people of Oakland and San Francisco
and Los Angeles see this move against
these undocumented immigrants in that
light they're going after
known criminal Robichaux rather look at
the numbers that we just put them up on
the screen but come on but you you gave
the sample of the 232 and I I grant you
that there were real criminals among
that's who's being targeted right now
point of the mayor remember this is not
me this is not Geraldo this is the mayor
of Oakland saying that they is a that is
a community where the crime has dropped
three straight years of law-abiding
immigrants who deserve to live free
without that we're not a deportation
doctor Gorka we're not talking about the
otherwise law-abiding still people
didn't respect our laws sovereignty as
it relates to immigration that's not who
we are talking about though here shown
and we're not talking about slaves being
recaptured the analogy is specious and
fallacious these are criminals a if you
came here illegally
you're not undocumented you're a
criminal and secondly more than a
hundred people who actually convicted
felons not suspected of crimes convicted
of violent felonies in America why are
we creating sanctuary cities for
criminals
it's insane are we a nation of Orca
isn't that decision whether or not to
create a sanctuary said isn't that for
that city to decide or that state when
the founding fathers created the federal
system they said the president is in
charge of immigration philosophy states
rights no no immigration has nothing to
do with the states the national border
isn't around calories immigration is in
the control of the executive the
founding fathers nothing has changed
maids don't control immigration they
don't mayor shap points to the case of a
mom who has been in the country 26 years
who has four citizen children totally
law-abiding working with the law who is
a criminal and deported she's a criminal
you go out there when ice comes that
immigrant group they pick one and Maria
they picked the dishwasher and they are
ms-13 Geraldo there's a reason that the
statue of justice in every courtroom in
America is blindfolded
it doesn't look at who you are with your
name is Juanita or whether it's
Sebastian if you broke a law you're a
criminal if your name is Clinton you
don't get a pass you are intentionally
confusing people know it's a crime by
calling these immigrants criminals when
the only crime they have the mitad the
lose their presence in this country
their weapons breaking or murdered or
you know then they're not the Society
hundred of them have 100 230 but the
hundreds of others who may be escaped
this mayor is not in any legal jeopardy
because she I can tell you I can tell
you this level of the White House and
they are looking into legal action
against the mesh breaking she's an
accomplice to law breaks the scuttlebutt
Shawn justice and she announced it and
she's she's tipping off those people
fence yeah I get that it offends people
but it's not illegal it is it is of
course it's illegal official information
and tip oh okay that's different
you sound like Bill Clinton at all the
times what is it seriously come on
well I got the information from here so
I honestly popular move by this mayor in
her community
it made me offensive in crazy California
but in crazy California but it is the
sixth largest economy in the country in
the in morale I've got I've gotten this
really happy doesn't matter where you
get the information from if you aren't
trusting justice it's a crime by one of
these criminal aliens that that would
have otherwise been deported would
somebody have blood on their hands that
they
lutely assisted in in state law if then
no no not if then because you know what
people and crimes do it again and again
it's called recidivism it it happens in
a handful of cases there are I got a
million undocumented immigrants in the
country tell me about today he went in
to meet with about why would a Vong
covered me with you with me what were
they doing what would I say you know i
two weeks ago I was at mar-a-lago at the
invitation of the president I was with
every other member of the family with
whom I was very close that during their
celebrity Ivanka and I did Celebrity
Apprentice together so she reached down
said come on down and have some tea so
it was had some tea it has some table I
actually had coffee she had water but it
was it's a Prime Minister Netanyahu's
downstairs I didn't I was upstairs with
their vodka we were talking about you
know what I got to give you a later time
this is such a better selfie than what
I'm used to not only kid Jared was on
his way out he stopped by to say hi and
you were talking about all the people in
DC that are alright it's not the
administration not absolutely and and
she is so noble and she is so efficient
and so effective and she wants the best
for the country she wants the best for
her dad and I am a hundred percent
behind her I think that me tell you she
and Jared a holiday the kids are settled
they have a nice home it is a blood
brutal dirty outrageous baby I just wish
it look it's hard yeah thanks alright
thank you thank you dr. Gork